The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Over the last several
lectures, we've dealt
with the representation of
linear time-invariant systems
through convolution.
And just to remind you of our
basic strategy, essentially,
the idea was to exploit the
notion of linearity by
decomposing the input into a sum
of basic inputs and then
using linearity to tell us
that the output can be
represented as the corresponding
linear
combination of the associated
outputs.
So, if we have a linear system,
either continuous-time
or discrete-time, for example,
with continuous time, if the
input is decomposed as a linear
combination of basic
inputs, with each of these basic
inputs generating an
associated output, and if the
system is linear, then the
output of the system is the same
linear combination of the
associated outputs.
And the same statement is
identical both for continuous
time and discrete time.
So the strategy is to decompose
the input into these
basic inputs.
And the inputs were chosen
also with some particular
strategy in mind.
In particular, for both
continuous time or discrete
time, in this representation,
the basic inputs used in the
decomposition are chosen, first
of all, so that a broad
class of signals could be
represented in terms of these
basic inputs, and second of all,
so that the response to
these basic inputs is, in some
sense, easy to compute.
Now, in the representation which
led us to convolution,
the particular choice that we
made in the discrete-time case
for our basic inputs was a
decomposition of the input in
terms of delayed impulses.
And the associated outputs
that that generated were
delayed versions of the
impulse response.
Decomposing the input into a
linear combination of these,
the output into the
corresponding linear
combination of these, then led
to the convolution sum in the
discrete time case.
And in the continuous-time
case, a similar kind of
decomposition, in terms of
impulses, and associated
representation of the output,
in terms of the impulse
response, led to the convolution
integral.
Now, in this lecture, and for
a number of the succeeding
lectures, we'll want to turn
our attention to a very
different set of basic
building blocks.
And in particular, the signals
that we'll be using as the
building blocks for our more
general signals, rather than
impulses, as we've dealt with
before, will be, in general,
complex exponentials.
So, in a general sense, in the
continuous-time case, we'll be
thinking in terms of a
decomposition of our signals
as a linear combination of
complex exponentials,
continuous-time, or, in the
discrete-time case, complex
exponentials, where z_k is
complex here in discrete time
and s sub k is complex here
in continuous time.
Now, the basic strategy, of
course, requires that we
choose a set of inputs, basic
building blocks, which have
two properties.
One is that the system response
be straightforward to
compute, or in some sense,
easy to compute.
And second is that it be a
fairly general set of building
blocks so that we can build lots
of signals out of them.
What we'll find with complex
exponentials, either
continuous-time or
discrete-time, is that they
very nicely have those
two properties.
In particular, the notion that
the output of a linear
time-invariant system is easy
to compute is tied to what's
referred to as the Eigenfunction
function
property of complex
exponentials, which we'll
focus on shortly in a
little more detail.
And second of all, the fact
that we can, in fact,
represent very broad classes
of signals as linear
combinations of these will be
a topic and an issue that
we'll develop in detail over,
in fact, the next set of
lectures, this lecture, and
the next set of lectures.
Now, in doing this, although we
could, in fact, begin with
our attention focused on, in
general, complex exponentials,
what we'll choose to do is first
focus on the case in
which the exponent in the
continuous-time case is purely
imaginary, as I indicate here,
and in the discrete-time case,
where the magnitude of
the complex number
z_k is equal to 1.
So what that corresponds to in
the continuous-time case is a
set of building blocks of the
form e^(j omega_k t), and in
the discrete-time case, a set of
building blocks of the form
e^(j Omega_k n).
What we'll see is a
representation in these terms
leads to what's referred
to as Fourier analysis.
And that's what will be dealing
with over the next set
of lectures.
We'll then be exploiting this
representation actually
through most of the course.
And then toward the end of the
course, we'll return to
generalizing the Fourier
representation to a discussion
Laplace transforms
and Z-transforms.
So for now, we want to restrict
ourselves to complex
exponentials of a particular
form, and in fact, also
initially to continuous-time
signals and systems.
So let's begin with the
continuous-time case and the
complex exponentials that we
want to deal with and focus,
first of all, on what I refer
to as the Eigenfunction
property of this particular
set of building blocks.
We're talking about basic
signals of the form e^(j
omega_k t).
And the statement is that for
a linear time-invariant
system, the response to one of
these is of exactly the same
form, just simply multiplied
by a complex factor, that
complex factor depending
on what the
frequency, omega_k, is.
Now more or less, the
justification for this, or the
proof, follows by simply looking
at the response to a
complex exponential, using
the convolution integral.
So if we put a complex
exponentials into a linear
time-invariant system with
impulse response h(t), then we
can express the response
as I've indicated here.
We can then recognize that this
complex exponentials can
be factored into two terms.
And so we can rewrite
this complex
exponential as this product.
Second, recognize that this term
can be taken outside the
integral, over here, because
of the fact that it depends
only on t and not on Tau.
And so what we're left with,
when we track this through, is
that, with a complex exponential
input, we get an
output which is the same complex
exponential, namely
this factor, times
this integral.
And this integral is what I
refer to above as H(omega_k).
And so, in fact, we put in a
complex exponential, we get
out a complex exponentials of
the same frequency, multiplied
by a complex constant.
And that is what's referred to
as the Eigenfunction property,
Eigenfunction meaning that an
Eigenfunction of a system, or
mathematical expression, is a
function which, when you put
it through the system, comes out
looking exactly the same
except for a change in
amplitude, the change in
amplitude being the
Eigenvalue.
So in fact, this function
is the Eigenfunction.
And this value is
the Eigenvalue.
OK, now it's because of the
Eigenfunction property that
complex exponentials are
particularly convenient as
building blocks.
Namely you put it through the
system, they come out with the
same form and simply scale.
The other part to the question,
related to the
strategy that we've been
pursuing, is to hope that
these signals can be used as
building blocks to represent a
very broad class of signals
through a linear combination.
And in fact, that turns out to
be the case with complex
exponentials.
As we work our way through that,
we'll first consider the
case of periodic signals.
And what that leads to is a
representation of periodic
signals through what's called
the Fourier series.
Following that, we'll turn our
attention to non-periodic, or
as I refer to it, aperiodic
signals.
And the representation that's
developed in terms of linear
combinations of complex
exponentials is what's
referred to as the Fourier
transform.
So the first thing we want to
deal with are periodic signals
and the Fourier series.
So what we're talking about then
is the continuous-time
Fourier series.
And the Fourier series is a
representation for periodic
continuous-time signals.
We have a signal, then,
which is periodic.
And we're choosing T_0
to denote the period.
So it's T_0 that corresponds
to the period of
our periodic signal.
omega_0 is 2 pi / T_0, as you
recall from our discussion pf
periodic signals and
sinusoids before.
And that's 2 pi f_0.
So this is the fundamental
frequency.
Now let's examine, first of all,
complex exponentials, and
recognize, first of all, that
there is a complex exponential
that has exactly the same
period and fundamental
frequency as our more general
periodic signal, namely the
complex exponential e^(j omega_0
t), where omega_0 is 2
pi / T_0, or equivalently,
T_0 is 2 pi / omega_0.
Now that's the complex
exponential which has T_0 as
the fundamental period.
But there are harmonically
related complex exponentials
that also have T_0 as a period,
although in fact,
their fundamental period
is shorter.
So we can also look at complex
exponentials of the form e^(j
k omega_0 t).
These likewise are periodic
with a period of T_0.
Although, in fact, their
fundamental period is T_0 / k,
or equivalently, 2 pi divided
by their fundamental
frequency, k omega_0.
So as k, an integer, varies,
these correspond to
harmonically related complex
exponentials.
Now what the Fourier series
says, and we'll justify this
bit by bit as the discussion
goes on, what the Fourier
series says, and in fact, what
Fourier said, which was
essentially his brilliant
insight, is that, if I have a
very general periodic signal, I
can represent it as a linear
combination of these
harmonically-related complex
exponentials.
So that representation is what
I've indicated here.
And this summation is what will
be referred to as the
Fourier series.
And as we proceed with the
discussion, there are two
issues that will develop.
One is, assuming that our
periodic signal can be
represented this way, how do
we determine the Fourier
series coefficients, as they're
referred to, a_k.
That's one question.
And the second question will
be how broad a class of
signals, in fact, can be
represented this way.
And that's another question
that we'll deal with
separately.
Now just focusing on this
representation for a minute,
this representation of the
Fourier series, which I've
repeated again here, is what's
referred to as the complex
exponential form of the
Fourier series.
And it's important to note,
incidentally, that the
summation involves frequencies,
k omega_0, that
are both positive
and negative.
In other words, this index k
runs over limits that include
both negative values and
positive values.
Now that complex exponential
form is one representation for
the Fourier series.
And in fact, it's the one that
we will be principally relying
on in this course.
There is another representation
that perhaps
you've come across previously
and that in a variety of other
contexts is typically used,
which is called the
trigonometric form for
the Fourier series.
Without really tracking
through the algebra,
essentially we can get to the
trigonometric form from the
complex exponential form by
recognizing that if we express
the complex coefficient in polar
form or in rectangular
form and expand the complex
exponential term out in terms
of cosine plus j sine, using
just simply Euler's relation,
then we will end up with a
representation for the
periodic signal, or a
re-expression of the Fourier
series expression that we had
previously, either in the form
that I indicate here, where
now the periodic signal is
expressed in terms of a
summation of cosines with
appropriate amplitude
and phase.
Or another equivalent
trigonometric form involves
rearranging this in terms
of a combination
of cosines and sines.
Now in this representation,
the frequencies of the
sinusoids vary only over
positive frequencies.
And typically one thinks of
periodic signals as having
positive frequencies associated
with them.
However, let's look back and the
complex exponential form
for the Fourier series at
the top of the board.
And in that representation,
when we use this
representation, we'll find it
convenient to refer to both
positive frequencies and
negative frequencies.
So the representation that we
will most typically be using
is the complex exponential
form.
And in that form, what we'll
find as we think of
decomposing a periodic signal
into its components at
different frequencies, it will
involve both positive
frequencies and negative
frequencies.
Okay, now we have the Fourier
series representation, as I've
indicated here.
Again, so far I've sidestepped
the issue as to whether this
in fact represents all
the signals that
we'd like to represent.
Let's first address the issue
of how we determine these
coefficients a_k, assuming
that, in fact, this
representation is valid.
And again, I'll kind
of move through the
algebra fairly quickly.
The algebraic steps are ones
that you can pursue more
leisurely just to kind
of verify them and
step through them.
But essentially, the algebra
develops out of the
recognition that if we
integrate a complex
exponential over one
period, T_0--
and I mean by this notation that
this is an integral over
a period, where I don't
particularly care where the
period starts and where the
period stops, in other words,
exactly what period I picked--
that this integral is equal to
T_0 when m is equal to 0.
And it's equal to 0 if
m is not equal to 0.
That follows simply from the
fact that if we substitute in
for using or Euler's relation,
so that we have the integral
of a cosine plus j times the
sine, if m is not equal to 0,
then both of these integrals
over a period are 0.
The integral of a of a periodic
of a sinusoid, cosine
or sine, over an integral
number of periods is 0.
Whereas, if m is equal to 0,
this integral will be equal to
T_0, the integral
of the cosine.
And the integral of the
sine is equal to 0.
Okay, well, the next step in
developing the expression for
the coefficient a_k is to refer
back to the Fourier
series expression, which was
that x(t) is equal to the sum
of a_k e^(j k omega_0 t).
If we multiply both sides of
that by e^(-j n omega_0 t),
and integrate that
over a period--
both sides of the equation
integrated over a period, so
these two equations
are equal--
and then in essence, interchange
the summation and
the integration so that this
part of the expression comes
outside the sum, and then we
combine these two complex
exponentials together, where we
come out is the expression
that I've indicated here.
And then essentially what
happens at this point,
algebraically, is that we use
the result that we just
developed to evaluate
this integral.
So multiplying both sides of
the Fourier series and then
doing the integration leads
us, after the appropriate
manipulation, to the expression
that I have up here.
And this integral is equal to
T_0 if k is equal to n,
corresponding to 0 up here.
And it's 0 otherwise, which is
what we had demonstrated or
argued previously.
And the upshot of all that,
then, is that the right hand
side of this expression
disappears except for the term
when k is equal to n.
And so finally, we have what I
indicate here, taking T_0 and
moving it over to the other
side of the equation, that
then tells us how we determine
the Fourier series
coefficients a_n, or a_k.
So that, in effect, then is
what we refer to as the
analysis equation, the equation
that begins with x(t)
and tells us how to get the
Fourier series coefficients.
What I'll refer to as the
Fourier series synthesis
equation is the equation that
tells us how to build x(t) out
of these complex exponentials.
So we have the synthesis
equation, which is the one we
started from.
We have the analysis equation,
which is the equation that we
just developed.
So we in effect have gone
through the issue of, assuming
that a Fourier series
representation is in fact
valid, how we get the
coefficients.
We'll want to address somewhat
the question of how broad a
class of signals are
we talking about.
And what's in fact amazing,
and was Fourier's amazing
insight, was that it's a very
broad class of signals.
But let's first look at just
some examples in which we take
a signal, assume that it
has the Fourier series
representation, and see what
the Fourier series
coefficients look like.
So we'll begin with what I refer
to as an antisymmetric
periodic square wave--
periodic of course, because
we're talking about periodic
signals; square wave referring
to its shape; and
antisymmetric referring
to the fact that it
is an odd time function.
In other words, it is
antisymmetric about the origin.
Now the expression for the
Fourier series coefficients
tells us that we determine a_k
by taking 1 / T0 times the
integral over a period of x(t),
e^(-j k omega_0 t) dt.
The most convenient thing in
this case is to choose a
period, which let's say goes
from -T_0 / 2 to +T_0 / 2.
So here x(t) is -1.
Here x(t) is +1.
And so I've expressed the
Fourier series coefficients as
this integral, that's
from -T_0 / 2 to 0.
And then added to that is the
positive part of the cycle.
And so we have these
two integrals.
Now, I don't want to track
through the details of the
algebra again.
I guess I've decided that that's
much more fun for you
to do on your own.
But the way it comes out when
you go through it is the
expression that I finally
indicate after suggesting that
there are few more
steps to follow.
And what develops is that those
two integrals together,
for k not equal to 0, come
out to this expression.
And that expression is
not valid for k = 0.
For k equal to 0, we can go back
to the basic expression
for the Fourier series, which is
1 / T_0, the integral over
a period, x(t) e^(-j
k omega_0 t) dt.
For k = 0, of course this term
just simply becomes 1.
And so the zeroth coefficient is
1 / T_0 times the integral
of x(t) over a period.
Now, going back to the original
function that we
have, what we're saying then is
that the zeroth coefficient
is 1 / T_0 times the integral
over one period, which is, in
effect, the average value.
And it's straightforward to
verify for this case that
average value is equal to 0.
Now let's look at these Fourier
series coefficients on
a bar graph.
And I've indicated that here.
The expression for the
Fourier series
coefficients we just developed.
And it involves--
it's 0 for k = 0, it's
a factor of this
form for k =/= 0.
Plotted on a bar graph, then we
see values like this, 0 at
k = 0 and then associated
values.
And there are a number of things
to focus on when you
look at this.
One is the fact that the Fourier
series coefficients
for this example are
purely imaginary.
A second is that the Fourier
series coefficients for this
example are an odd sequence.
In other words, if you look at
this sequence, what you see
are these values for
-k flipped over.
So they're imaginary and odd.
And what that results in, when
you look at the trigonometric
form of the Fourier series,
is that in fact, those
conditions, if you put the terms
all together, lead you
to a trigonometric
representation, which involves
only sine terms--
in other words, no
cosine terms.
Let me just draw your attention
to the fact that,
since a_k's are imaginary, this
j takes care of that fact
so that these coefficients
are in fact real.
So what this says is that for
the antisymmetric square wave,
in effect, the Fourier series
is a sine series.
The antisymmetric square wave
is an odd function.
Sinusoids are odd functions.
And so this is all kind of
reasonable, that we're
building an odd function
out of odd functions.
As an additional aside, which
I won't exploit or refer to
any further here, but just draw
your attention to, is
that another aspect of this
periodic square wave, the
particular one that we chose, is
that it is what's referred
to as an odd harmonic
function.
In other words, for even values
of k, the Fourier
series coefficients are 0.
They're are only non-zero
for odd values of k.
Now let's look at
another example.
Another example is
the symmetric
periodic square wave.
And this is in fact example 4.5,
worked out in more detail
in the text.
Then I won't bother to work
this out in detail here,
except to draw your attention
to several points.
Here is the symmetric periodic
square wave.
And what I mean by symmetric
is that it's
an even time function.
Now just kind of extrapolating
your intuition, what you
should expect is that if it's
only an even time function, it
should be built up or buildable,
if it's buildable
at all, out of only
even sinusoids.
And in fact, that's the case.
So if we look at the Fourier
series coefficients for this,
is zeroth coefficient, again, is
the average value, which in
this case, is 1/2.
Here I've plotted pi times the
Fourier series coefficients.
So the zeroth value is pi / 2.
The coefficients are now an even
sequence, in other words,
symmetric about k = 0.
And the consequence of that is
that when you take these
coefficients and put together
the equivalent trigonometric
form, the trigonometric form
involves only cosines and no
sine terms.
Now you'll see this in other
examples, not that we'll do in
the lecture, but examples in
the text and in the video
manual, if in fact the square
wave was neither symmetric or
antisymmetric, then the
trigonometric form would
involve both sines
and cosines.
And that is, of course,
the more general case.
Furthermore, in the two examples
I've shown here, in
both cases, the signal
is odd harmonic.
In other words, for even values
of k, the coefficients
are equal to 0.
Although I won't justify that
here, that's a consequence of
the fact that this symmetry is
exactly about half a period.
And if you made the on time of
the square wave different in
relation to the off
time, then that
property would also disappear.
Now what's kind of amazing,
actually, is that if we take a
square wave, like I have
here or as I had in the
antisymmetric case, the
implication is that I can
build that square wave
by adding up
enough sines or cosines.
And it really seems kind of
amazing because the square
wave, after all, is a very
discontinuous function.
Sinusoids are very continuous.
And it seems puzzling that
in fact you can do that.
Well let's look in a little
bit of detail how the
sinusoidal terms add up to
build a square wave.
And to do that, let's first
define what I refer to as a
partial sum.
So here we have the expression
which is the synthesis
equation, telling us how x(t)
could be represented as
complex exponentials
if it can be.
And let's consider just
a finite number of
terms in this sum.
And so x_n(t), of course, as n
goes to infinity, approaches
the infinite sum that
we're talking about.
And although we could do this
more generally, let's not.
Let's focus on the symmetric
square wave case, where
because of the symmetry of these
coefficients, namely
that a_k is equal to a_(-k), we
can rewrite these terms as
cosine terms.
And so this partial sum can
be expressed the way I'm
expressing it here.
Well let's look at a
few of these terms.
On the graph, I have, first
of all, x(t), which is our
original square wave.
The term that I indicate here
is the factor of 1/2,
which is this term.
With n = 1, that would
correspond to adding one
cosine term to that.
And so the sum of those two
would be this, which looks a
little closer to the square
wave, but certainly not very
close to it at all.
And in fact, it's somewhat hard
to imagine without seeing
the terms build up how in fact,
by adding more and more
terms, we can generate something
that is essentially
flat, except at the
discontinuities.
So let's look at this example.
And what I'd like to show is
this example, but now as we
add many more terms to it.
And let's see in fact how these
individual terms add up
to build up the square wave.
So this is the square wave
that we want to build up
through the Fourier series
as a sum of sinusoids.
And the term for k = 0 will be
a constant which represents
the DC value of this.
And so in the partial sum, as we
develop it, the first thing
that we'll show is just
the term for k = 0.
Now for k = 1, we would add to
that one sinusoidal term.
And so the sum of the term
for k = 1 and k = 0
is represented here.
Now when we go to k = 2, because
of the fact that this
is an odd harmonic function,
in fact, the term for k = 2
will have zero amplitude and
so this won't change.
Here we show the Fourier
series with k = 2
and there's no change.
And then we will go to k = 3.
And we will be adding,
then, one
additional sinusoidal term.
Here is k = 3.
When we go to k = 4, again,
there won't be any change.
But there will be another term
that's added at k = 5 here.
Then k = 6, again, because it's
odd harmonic, no change.
And finally k = 7
is shown here.
And we can begin to see that
this starts to look somewhat
like the square wave.
But now to really emphasize how
this builds up, let's more
rapidly add many more terms,
and in fact increase the
number of terms up to about
100, recognizing that the
shape will only change on the
inclusion of the odd-numbered
terms, not the even-numbered
terms, because it's an odd
harmonic function.
So now we're increasing and
we're building up toward k =
100, 100 terms.
And notice that it is the
higher-order terms that tend
to build up the discontinuity
corresponding to the notion
that the discontinuity, or sharp
edges in a signal, in
fact, are represented through
the higher frequencies in the
Fourier series.
And here we have a
not-too-unreasonable
approximation to the original
square wave.
There is the artifact of the
ripples at the discontinuity.
And in fact, that rippling
behavior at the discontinuity
is referred to the
Gibbs phenomenon.
And it's an inherent part
of the Fourier series
representation at
discontinuities.
Now to emphasize this, let's
decrease the number
of terms back down.
And we will carry this down to
k = 1, again to emphasize how
the sinusoids are building
up the square wave.
Here we are back at k = 1.
And then finally, we will add
back in the sinusoids
that we took out.
And let's build this back up
to 100 terms, showing the
approximation that we generated
with 100 terms to
the square wave.
Okay, so what you saw is that,
in fact, we got awfully close
to a square wave.
And the other thing that was
kind of interesting about it
as it went along was the
fact that, with the low
frequencies, what we were
tending to build was the
general behavior.
And as the higher frequencies
came in, that tended
contribute to the
discontinuity.
And in fact, something that will
stand out more and more
as we go through our discussion
of Fourier series
and Fourier transforms, is that
general statement, that
it's the low-frequency terms
that represent the broad time
behavior, and it's the
high-frequency terms that are
used to build up the sharp
transitions in the time domain.
Now we need to get a little
more precise about the
question of how, in fact, the
Fourier series, or when the
Fourier series represents the
functions that we're talking
about and in what sense
they represent them.
And so if we look again at the
synthesis equation, what we
really want to ask is, if we add
up enough of these terms,
in what sense does this sum
represent this time function?
Well, let's again use the notion
of our partial sum.
So we have the partial
sum down here.
And we can think of the
difference between this
partial sum and the original
time function as the error.
And I've defined
the error here.
And what we would like to know
is does this error decrease as
we add more and more terms?
And in fact, in what sense, if
the error does decrease, in
what sense does it decrease?
Now in detail this is
a fairly complicated
and elaborate topic.
I don't mean to make that
sound frightening.
It's mainly a statement
that I don't want to
explore in a lot of detail.
But it relates to what it's
referred to as the issue of
convergence of the
Fourier series.
And the convergence of the
Fourier series, the bottom
line on it, the kind of end
statement, can be made in
several ways.
One statement related to the
convergence of the Fourier
series is the following.
If I have a time function, which
is what is referred to
as square integrable, namely
its integral, over
a period, is finite.
Then what you can show, kind
of amazingly, is that the
energy in that error, in other
words, the energy and the
difference between the original
function and the
partial sum, the energy
in that, goes to 0
as n goes to infinity.
A somewhat tighter condition is
a condition referred to as
it Dirichlet conditions, which
says that if the time function
is absolutely integrable, not
square integrable, but
absolutely integrable--
and I've kind of hedged the
issue by just simply referring
to x(t) as being
well behaved--
then the statement is that the
error in fact goes to 0 as n
increases, except at the
discontinuities.
And what well behaved means in
that statement is that, as
discussed in the book, there are
a finite number of maxima
and minima in any period and
a finite number of finite
discontinuities, which is,
essentially, always the case.
So under square integrability
what we have is the statement
not that the partial sum goes
to the right value at every
point, but that the energy
in the error goes to 0.
Under the Dirichlet conditions,
it says that, in
fact, the signal goes to the
right value at every time
instant except at the
discontinuities.
So going back to the square
wave, the square wave
satisfies either one of
those conditions.
And so what the consequence is
is that, with the square wave,
if we looked at the error, then
in fact what we would
find is that the energy in the
error would go to zero as we
add more and more terms
in the partial sum.
And in fact, since the square
wave also satisfies the
Dirichlet conditions, the actual
value of the error, the
difference between the partial
sum and the true value, will
actually go to 0.
That difference will go to 0
except at the discontinuities.
And that, in fact, is kind of
evident as we watch the
function build up by adding
up these terms.
And so in fact, let's go back
and see again the development
of the partial sums
in relation to the
original time function.
Let's observe, this time again,
basically what we saw
before, which is that it builds
up to the right answer.
And furthermore what we'll
plot this time, also as a
function of time, is the
energy in the error.
And what we'll see is that the
energy in the error will be
tending towards 0 as the number
of terms increases.
So once again, we have
the square wave.
And we want to again show the
buildup of the Fourier series,
this time showing also how the
energy in the error decreases
as we add more and more terms.
Well, once again, we'll begin
with k = 0, corresponding to
the constant term.
And what's shown on the bottom
trace is the energy in the
error between those two.
And we'll then add the term k
= 1 to the DC term and we'll
see that the energy will
decrease when we do that.
Here we have then the sum
of k = 0 and k = 1.
Now with k = 2, the energy won't
decrease any further
because it's an odd
harmonic function.
That's what we've
just added in.
When we add in the term for k
= 3, again, we'll see the
energy in the error decrease
as reflected
in the bottom curve.
So there we are at k = 3.
When we go to k = 4,
there again is no
change in the error.
At k = 5, again the
error decreases.
k = 6, there will be
no change again.
And at k = 7, the energy
decreases.
And now let's show how the error
decreases by building up
the number of terms
much more rapidly.
Already the error has gotten
somewhat small on the scale in
which we're showing it, so let's
expand out the error
scale, the vertical axis
displaying the energy in the
error, so that we could watch
how the energy decreases as we
add more and more terms.
So here we have the vertical
scale expanded.
And now what we'll do is
increase the number of terms
in the Fourier series and watch
the energy in the error
decreasing, always decreasing,
of course, on the inclusion of
the odd-numbered terms and not
on the inclusion of the
even-numbered terms because of
the fact that it's an odd
harmonic function.
Now the energy in the error
asymptotically will approach
0, although point by point, the
Fourier series will never
be equal to the square wave.
It will, at every instant
of time, except at the
discontinuities, where there
will always be some ripple
corresponding to what's referred
to as the Gibbs
phenomenon.
So what we've seen, then, is
a quick look at the Fourier
series representation
of periodic signals.
We more broadly want to have a
more general representation of
signals in terms of complex
exponentials.
And so our next step will
be to move toward a
representation of nonperiodic
or aperiodic signals.
Now the details of this, I leave
for the next lecture.
The only thought that I want to
introduce at this point is
the basic strategy which is
somewhat amazing and kind of
interesting to reflect
on in the interim.
The basic strategy with an
aperiodic signal is to think
of representing this aperiodic
signal as a linear combination
of complex exponentials by the
simple trick of periodically
replicating this signal,
generating a periodic signal
using a Fourier series
representation for that
periodic signal, and then simply
letting the period go
to infinity.
As the period goes to infinity,
that periodic signal
becomes the original aperiodic
one that we had before.
And the Fourier series
representation then becomes
what we'll refer to the
Fourier transform.
So that's just a quick look at
the basic idea and approach
that we'll take.
In the next lecture, we'll
develop this a little more
carefully and more fully,
moving from the Fourier
series, which we've used for
periodic signals, to develop
the Fourier transform, which
will then be representation
for aperiodic signals.
Thank you.